un budget de transition pour saint
quentin en yvelines c'est ainsi que
stéphane mirambeau vice président en
charge de ce dossier a introduit les
débats ce 30 mars entre intégration de
nouvelles communes depuis janvier 2016
nouvelles compétences maintien des aides
aux associations et diminution des
dotations de l'état
il a fallu composer je dirais que c'est
un budget qui a été encore relativement
simple à et à équilibrer attention la
suite il y a des mauvaises nouvelles sur
man qui arrive la réforme de la dgf qui
se poursuivra encore l'amendement exane
qui va arriver en fait à son terme
encore une fois donc là dès 2017 j'irai
encore assez simple à 2018 risque d'être
beaucoup plus compliqué plus de 231
millions en fonctionnement et plus de 37
millions en investissements ce sont les
montants de ce budget pour 2010 est un
budget sans hausse de la fiscalité
marquée également par une anticipation
du remboursement de la dette et un
accent mis sur le développement
économique afin d'attirer petites
entreprises et grands groupes
reste que plusieurs débats ont été
houleux la notamment concernant le
traitement réservé à certaines communes
traitement jugé inéquitable par une
partie des élus minoritaires s'est pas
trop entre communes c'est plutôt la
question des relations financières entre
les communes et entre les communes et
l'agglomération c'est là où il ya des
interrogations qu'il faut qu'on pose sur
la table et qu'on tranche ona budget
cohérent il n'ya pas d'inégalité puisque
savez le budget il a été préparé avec
l'ensemble des élus de cette
agglomération est aujourd'hui au
contraire on cherche faire les choses
bien
un budget est finalement adopté par 49
voix pour et 23 contre le point d'étape
prévu sur l'élaboration du projet de
territoire qui doivent structurer saint
quentin pour les années à venir a été
reporté à la prochaine séance au regard
de l'heure tardive